- [Voiceover] Moussa and Fatu
were each asked to factor
the quadratic expression
16 x-squared minus 64.
Their responses are shown below.
So Moussa factored it this way.
Fatu factored it this way.
Which student wrote an
expression that is equivalent
to 16 x-squared minus 64?
So I encourage you to pause
the video and figure that out.
Which student wrote an
expression that is equivalent to
our original one, 16 x-squared minus 64?
Well let's work through it
together, so let's see if first
we can factor this out
somehow to get what Moussa got
and it looks like Moussa
first factored out a 16
and then he was left with
a difference of squares.
So let's see if we can do that.
So, we can write our original expression.
16 x-squared minus 64,
we can write that as
16 times x-squared
minus 16 times four.
And when you write it like
that, it's very clear that you
can factor out a 16.
So this is going to be equal to 16 times
what you have left over is x-squared
minus four and then x-squared minus four,
that's a difference of
squares right over there.
So, that part we can factor as,
so we have our original 16 and then...
this part right over here, we can write as
x plus two times x minus two.
If what I just did in this
last step, going from x-squared
minus four to x plus two times x minus two
doesn't make any sense, I
encourage you to watch some of
the introductory videos on factoring
and difference of squares.
But the basic idea, I have a form here of
a-squared minus b-squared, so
it's going to have the form
of a plus b times a minus b
and in this case it's
x-squared minus two squared.
So it's going to be x plus
two times x minus two.
So that's exactly what Moussa got.
So this one, so Moussa,
did get an expression
that is equivalent to
16 x-squared minus 64.
Now let's think about Fatu.
So Fatu didn't factor
out a 16 from the get-go.
It looks like he just
immediately recognized that
our original expression is
itself a difference of squares
even if we don't factor out a 16,
and so let's re-write it.
So our original expression, we could write
as, so instead of writing,
well I'm just going to
write it like this, this
is our original expression.
16 x-squared minus 64.
That's the same thing as, 16
x-squared is the same thing as
four x, the whole thing squared
and then minus eight squared.
So when you write it like
this, it's clear that this is a
difference of squares,
so this is going to be
four x plus eight times
four x minus eight.
Four x plus eight times
Once again, if this last
step that I did doesn't make
a lot of sense I encourage
you to watch the video
on factoring difference
of squares where we go
a lot more into the intuition of it.
But when you see it this
way you realize that Fatu
also got an expression
that is equivalent to
16 x-squared minus 64, so they both did.